the recipient of the fifth annual music
educator award an elementary school
music teacher in the south from there
the students and staff at PS 48 in New
York City last night celebrating music
teacher Melissa Salguero she was just
named winner of this year's Grammy music
edge agree educator award Salguero
studied and started her career in South
Florida she came to the South Bronx to
relaunch a music program that ended 30
years ago Michelle Miller recently went
to the school to meet the teacher and
some of her very grateful students
Michelle good morning good morning well
when Melissa Salguero first arrived at
PS 48 seven years ago there was a school
song no instruments there wasn't even a
mascot now the proud Tigers of PS 48
have an award-winning teacher and music
throughout the hall - ready in sync with
the sunrise if not yet with one another
almost these fifth graders at PS 48 in
Bronx arrived an hour early for band
practice you gotta push more air in the
instrument instruments in hand for just
four days Melissa Salguero guides the
first-time musicians through every note
you notice they come in before school
because we have so much need for them to
be in the classroom and and have them
get their math in the English so band is
a before school activity
[Music]
believe it or not progress comes quickly
here
this is last year's band performing
music from Adele just a few months after
getting their instruments at the end of
the day it's not going to be Carnegie
Hall you know but that's that's not what
we want what I want is I want the kids
to get the experience of working hard
have you ever seen teaching this age
especially it has to be something
dramatic it has to be something that's
going to grab their attention making a
musical carrot or a keyboard of bananas
I can do that I never had a teacher like
this like she's different so many
different ways like amazing
he Sal Sierra you Shawn green and Luis
Galvez are in the fifth grade band in
course he meets us feel special I wonder
seven but she doesn't care how we sing
and what we're trying to say is that she
makes our day she likes feel great and
if you've ever doubted the power of a
great teacher
you're getting emotional yes I am watch
Luis talk about what a big deal miss
Salguero really is not everything you
could to um meet a person that is so
important in your life and then we'll
teach you a bunch of things about life
and stuff yes 48 has its challenges
located in one of New York City's
poorest neighborhoods most families here
earn less than 25 thousand dollars a
year and 22 percent of the school
students are homeless still I feel like
I was born to teach at this school how
do you build a music program from the
ground up so when I started it was just
me and a guitar singing don't stop
believin it's been so long since I've
been here GNA Martinez is one of miss al
garrow's first music students here
[Music]
she now performs in community theater
and attends a competitive performing
arts high school she gave me a stage to
perform on whenever I was in band and so
I realized that I love being on stage
and I love to act and I love to sing
that love of performing and affection
for this music educator award winner is
why these students erupted before dawn
every day if there were no band then I
would only see you miss oh girl for one
day a week but then I'd rather see her
for a hold they come to school for music
they come to school for you what does
that mean to you
no one's ever put it that way I would
love for them to think back of their
time here not remember wake up early for
band practice I want them to remember I
worked so hard if they can remember that
I'll be happy I'll be so happy she is
happy well so garrow's win also comes
with a couple of checks for $10,000 one
for her another for the school badly
needed funds for a music program that
doesn't let the students have to buy
their instruments they get them free and
if you want to know what she's gonna use
her money for it she still has college
debt she will be paying it down you
should have brought a box of tissues
when you came to the set with that story
she's an amazing woman
oh my gosh what no those kids adore her
yeah you can tell and she adores them
she does why teachers do what they do
the really good teachers that's the kind
of thing they get from their students
love that story she has a love of
science too so while she's a music
teacher at heart she also has that
burgeoning science bug in her and that
it always Peaks out all right teasing
thanks and you can see the Recording
Academy 60th animal annual Grammy Awards
Sunday night at 7:30 right here on CBS